labor leaders past and present
in Leeds with a fresh pitch for power
and how best to balance it around the
country
a detailed vision for the UK's future
produced by the former prime minister
commissioned by the man who wants to be
the next if labor wins the next election
Britain will see a change not just in
who governs
but how we are governed labor will
rebuild Trust by reforming the center of
government
cleaning up slaves nourishing the
relationship between central government
and the devolved authorities
and replacing the unelected House of
Lords with a new smaller democratically
elected second chamber no more Naval
gazing or facing inwards
higher wider better
that is how Britain must set its size
but this a country with its sights set
on more pressing needs a cost of living
crisis happening right now at a time
when people are struggling to pay their
bills feed their families in a striking
overpay settlements you've produced a
155-page report talking about Devolution
constitutional reform and abolishing the
House of Lords this might look to many
people as completely out of touch I'm
fed up to the back teeth with sticking
plasters for the problems that we've got
the underlying problem is our economy
isn't working this is a strong
compelling set of recommendations that
do what politicians have all agreed
needs to be done but nobody's actually
done all these issues about the cost of
living and the strikes all the things
you ask us every day have one common
cause and that is our economy is not
working for everyone in this country it
is the mission of the next Labor
government to fight the election on that
issue to win it and to bring about the
change that we desperately desperately
need in this country in places like
Leeds where people are worried about
making ends meet getting a train or
seeing their doctor talk about
Devolution and constitutional reform may
seem a little bit abstract to their
everyday lives but for labor this is all
about trying to show the public that
they are a government in waiting with a
serious plan to level up the country and
keep the United Kingdom together
on their way to Edinburgh to make the
case for a United Kingdom
but the labor leader knows too that
money matters and people across the
Nations and regions of the UK want
politicians to prioritize it
the people are one of the main things
the High Cost of Living For example the
heating costs many other things real
strikes postal strikes
a labor leader now trying to punch back
through but converting his ambition into
reality a massive task the polls
promising but there's some way to go yet
Beth Rigby Sky News in Leeds